in general Flynn we saw Peter struck
snows now a lot of it was redacted idly
and I my sources have been telling me
and this program weeks that I've devoted
almost three years to unpeeling every
layer of the onion in fact what we now
know is that there was that Jack Flynn
was exonerated that the case was going
to be closed then Joe Biden brought up
the Logan Act which you mentioned
earlier $17.99 law nobody's ever been
prosecuted for now not only was it that
we've now learned that there was
premeditated fraud on a FISA Court to
spy on you as a candidate you and your
transition team and deep into your
presidency and James Comey signed three
of the four warrants but he came to you
after he signed the first one in Trump
Tower and said well again now we know
the bulk of information was Hillary's
dirty Russian disinformation dossier
made a lot of money for she paid for it
they knew it they said they had verified
it and turned out to be all untrue but
it ended up for you to be in the country
a three-year nightmare I question though
is this I mean general Flynn lost four
years of his life right Roger stones
supposed to report to jail and the jury
foreperson in his case
palmat affords case was dead and they
and many people that work for you paid
how much in lawyer's fees over this lie
so start in reverse order Paul Manafort
they sent in a book it looked like he
got all sorts of cash it turned out to
be a fraud what they did to that man
what they did to Paul might afford Roger
stone what they've done to Rajasthan
because he knew me he wasn't on the
campaign except the very very beginning
what they did with Roger stone what they
did to general Flynn and how about
Papadopoulos I didn't know Papadopoulos
but what they put him through he turned
out to be totally they had a tape of
this conversation that was supposed to
be this conversation was like a perfect
conversation they also have a tape of
Flynn's conversation with the Russian
ambassador which is a normal thing to do
you're going to have that position you
start calling up because you want to
coordinate between countries and the
tape was as I you said with the Russia
with the Ukrainian situation it was a
perfect
it was a perfect conversation that he
had what they've done to jerk to general
Flynn who's a nice man
tough guy smart guy a great general I'll
tell you general Milley said he's one of
the finest people you know he's just a
good man Flynn what happened to him the
way they went after him and if you
remember you remember well the FBI left
I said he did nothing wrong they said he
didn't lie they didn't say like they
said he didn't lie
they persecuted he threatened to put his
son and go after a son they said to me
what was the toughest friends of mine
what's the toughest country to deal with
who is it is it China is it Russia could
it be North Korean no it's the United
States of America the toughest country
to deal with because we have Schumer and
Pelosi and people that are bad people
that I honestly believe don't love our
country what they do to our country and
what they've done with this scam the
whole scam Flynn is a piece of it the
Muller scam now it came out that Muller
should have announced in the first week
that we did nothing wrong in other words
they had evidence in the first few days
that there was no collusion with Russia
there was nothing to do with Russia they
knew that immediately he didn't have to
take two or two-and-a-half years
they knew it immediately what they put
this country through Jeff Sessions was a
disaster he was a total disaster because
he basically let it happen unknowingly
because he's not very smart but they let
it happen and and it's a shame what they
put this country through as you look we
now have a durum report we now have the
Inspector General report I would imagine
that's probably going to be indictments
at the end of this when you look at the
names of the people for example the jury
foreperson and Roger stones case was
prejudiced against that was not a fairly
marginal even can you believe it the
hatred that she had for him and for me
and you and she said oh no I don't know
she acted like she was an innocent she
ran for Congress or something and lost
but she was like pretending to be an
innocent how did she even get into the
jury pool she must have had a little
contact but and the judge who's been
brutal the judge who sentenced roger has
been brutal take a look at what she's
done to people
same judge in the matter for case well
let's take a look at what you did for
Hillary late related things okay
wasn't brutal there but look at what
what she did to people just take a look
at what she's done and Roger stone had a
jury foreman for a woman who was a
disaster
how that's not declared a mistrial or
more than a mistrial is incredible to
anybody that sees it this is a person
that hated Roger stone hated me and
obviously said wonderful things
otherwise she couldn't have gone and it
looks like he reports to jail I believe
in four days yeah are you thinking about
a pardon already I don't want to get in
on your face but I think he was treated
very unfairly clearly though other than
he may have been evolved very early on
and I've known him for a long time but
I've known him like everybody in
Washington know him you have a lot of
guys in Washington they do he was not
involved in the campaign maybe a little
bit at the very very beginning but he
wasn't in fight he wasn't a part of the
campaign but he's a professional they've
destroyed his life totally destroyed his
life what they've done to Roger stone is
incredible and the jury forewoman stands
out and to have at least not give him a
new trial is inconceivable and by the
way she was a dominant person the jurors
said she was very dominating in the room
she dominated he got a tremendously big
sentence you see these guys they're
burning down buildings they're ripping
down statues they're hurting police they
don't go to jail nothing happens to him
they give they wanted to give him nine
years in jail process crime yeah if that
if that and then you have these
prosecutors who were Muller related the
whole Muller related thing one friend
said to me you have to be the most
innocent man in the history of the
United States I had 18 angry Democrat
geniuses all smart smarter sell Muller
lost it but they were all smart as hell
all these guys were after me they spent
forty five forty nine fifty five I hear
all different numbers men
dollars over a period of two and a half
years and they got nothing on me it was
I think I am that probably friend of
mine said you have to be the most
perfect person